my strength is sticking around and
seeing if Cody would be willing to work
on a relationship so I leave that door
open
but I'm not pining away for it Sister
Wives star Mary Brown fighting to save
her marriage to Cody I was with all
relationships you know whether it's
spouses or friends or family or Sisters
You've Got the ups and downs you just do
and it's just a matter of what your
commitment level is Mary's commitment
level may be clearer than ever as she
voices her frustration with Christine's
decision to lead their plural marriage I
felt angry and I feel a little betrayed
and I feel like I understand where she's
coming from
and I also know that anger is a
secondary emotion I'm I'm hurt you know
I'm hurt that she doesn't see value
enough in our family once I decided to
just I kind of looked at where my life
was and before I decided to leave and
I'm like do I really want to do this for
another 10 years Mary's angry Outburst
comes after Christine broke the news she
found a house in Utah and is officially
moving away from the rest of the family
in Arizona I didn't look back I never
looked back I just started moving
forward after Christine's confession
Mary explains why she chooses not to
leave despite the fact that the two
haven't lived together or been intimate
for years I don't feel
jealous of Christine that she's leaving
and I can't because I can I can do
whatever I want well the closure that
she's saying that she gets is that she
just decides and he just kind of goes
along with it Cody and I are in this
situation
we're not legally married
I want to work on the relationship but
Cody has basically said that he doesn't
does that mean we're just not married
anymore
that's not how I consider it
I feel like we're still married yeah but
Cody's seen things a little differently
I don't really consider myself married
to Mary
I just if she wanted to if she wanted to
move on and marry another she wouldn't
get an argument with me I don't believe
that we can ever be functional
and I don't believe that I will ever be
emotionally safe with her it's a strange
marriage it's it's a marriage that needs
to work out some stuff and the Brown
family patriarch explains why his
situation with Mary is different from
Christine's Mary and I have been
unraveling our relationship for years
Christine found out that she would never
be happy married to me but her leaving
was so sudden
that I
it wasn't unraveled for me it was like I
was being kicked to the curb
and that was the difference Mary and
Cody's relationship has been strained
since 2015 after she found herself
involved in a catfishing Scandal I
thought I was talking to a man online
it wasn't a man
it was a woman
pretending to be a man but it seems the
two have moved past that at least that's
what Cody told E.T last year we're
amiable we've had a real struggle and
this year we have some very difficult
conversations but that conversation
includes
hey
I'm not mad anymore I'm Not Angry
Anymore I'm not hurt anymore
so you know that's real progress
[Music]